how you guys doing today good thanks how
are you yeah I'm good I'm doing
fantastic are you gonna say thank you so
much for coming in how many times have
you guys been to a comic-con and
WonderCon two times three times two or
three times I've never been to WonderCon
I've been to comic-con they think two or
three times yeah three times I've never
been to one to con but I've been to
comic-con I think three times this isn't
my first time at WonderCon is this
anything that you like geek out about
that like applies to this audience like
if you had the ability to go downstairs
and let go shopping is there anything
that you would want to go buy swart a
sword a cool like medieval sword source
like the way you say it I really say
sword but I would put it's fun to say I
just want to find all the furries but
it's it's few far and few between this
what I'm saying I want to hunt it I want
to hunt it's wabbit season
oh do you not know what go down the hole
with me you know what I mean really I
was gonna say yeah no definitely look it
up later though you might you might be a
whole new thing for you really right yes
am i a changer change your life okay
joking it's why I get to talk to you
guys today first of all I cannot wait to
see the movie I saw like the opening I
guess 10 or 15 minutes ice and it was
awesome and completely different than
the the previous x-men movies so could
you sort of talk a little bit about that
like what did Simon as writer-director
bring to this that maybe is different
than the previous ones
it's gonna be refreshing to everyone
that's a fan of the comic book
installments kind of leading it with
more of the relationship-based
foundation rather than anything that is
more of a flicker fulfillment with you
know explosions and things like that as
much as we have that it's not what leads
that movie it's what truly should lead
the movie which is relationships and
emotion I feel yeah it was fun working
with Simon because he is so particular
and intricate with every little detail
that you kind of really do feel like
you're getting sucked into the storyline
are sucked into whatever we're getting
he I mean he gets you there on the day
and then you're able to kind of
hopefully it turns out right you know
yeah I mean it was a great environment
to work on the set with Simon he's the
writer as well so he knows it through
and through so it was uh I don't know I
just felt more relaxed and calm on set
so that was a great addition one of the
things is all of these movies have these
big action set pieces you know you're
gonna get that but for me my favorite
parts are getting to watch like the
banter between the characters and the
relationships because ultimately if you
don't care about these people you don't
give a [ __ ] what's going on with the
action sorry for my language sir right
so but talk a little bit about that like
maybe some of the cool scenes between
the characters and some of the banter
you get to go back and forth on I think
there's a lot of really beautiful
moments especially when we're talking
about Jean and her becoming Dark Phoenix
everyone kind of weighs in at some point
or another but what's beautiful is you
get to see the relationship the
backstory that's there so that when we
are talking about what we're going to do
about this person who's you know
basically losing their mind it's coming
from a place of love and there's some
real specific choices there that I think
the audience will really appreciate
which is that just because you love
someone doesn't mean that the things
that they do are you know okay or able
to just be kind of written off and when
you kind of have to stand up to someone
you love
it really starts to mess with your head
a lot and we all kind of come together
as a family in a sense
give me thank you guys went out she kind
of nailed it yeah I'll hold you later
yeah on a weird way when you think back
on the making of the film what's like
the day you will always remember if you
have one being on the space was pretty
anxious I'd say yeah I was this it was
the spaceship definitely space yet yeah
I was gonna say I don't want to do
spoilers because not everyone will be
fortunate enough to see the beginning of
the movie but that is the beginning of
the movie is it really yeah this stuff
right it sets everything in motion yes
it's the it's the first domino and the
thing is people really like the the set
pieces that involve your character
because of what is able to be done with
the camerawork and it's really badass in
space none of us have seen anything
oh my god they have a fake zero-g and
zero genes and zero-g right it's very
weird that I've seen more footage than
you I don't understand that at the panel
you'll probably be watching yeah the
first 15 minutes that's nice but the
thing is it's Marvel you know what I
mean and you know actors are the biggest
mouths in Hollywood I think so it's like
yo did you see the movie yeah I really
liked that one moment and then they
click so you know spoiler alert everyone
knows what happened in the movie so I
think that they kind of try and keep it
under lock and key
sure as well though you know the whole
movie and yeah I mean like we know
everything we read but I mean also
listen it's based on it's based on the
comics you know the storyline I think if
people really want to know
some they can take some educated guesses
sure you know so I have to ask you guys
obviously it's out there that Disney
bought Fox
so I guess my big huge question is have
you asked for a free annual passport yet
now that you're sort of related to
Disney not yet but that is a great idea
it's right around the corner I'm very
excited it is I would love to go skip
the line all that stuff give me a fast
path be amazing yeah at least and which
leads me to my next thing all of us
everyone loves going to Disneyland or
Disney World what is the ride of choice
for each of you
Tower chair I was gonna say tower chair
as well it's not the Tower of Terror
anymore though is whatever it's like
some weird elevator yeah I mean I think
it's I don't know maybe it's not an
elevator know what it would be but I
don't know I think it's something about
the galaxy Guardians in which the
guardians of the galaxy you're right
yeah I don't know what it's called I
think it's called literally guardians of
the galaxy breakout or something like
you're in an elevator but it's guardians
it's a Guardians elevator yeah something
like that yeah I like the dog what's it
Space Mountain yeah dark mouth okay it's
dark in there
so yeah sure this one of the things
about this movie is you guys have this
big cast what is it like when do you
guys ever go out together as like a
group to a bar or like for food and what
is that kind of like after like a long
day of getting loopy filming I mean it's
actually kind of nice it's crazy yeah we
get we get together we eat we talk about
our families and our significant others
we you drink we drink you know we say
goodbye to each other and we go to bed
early it's very normal
all right yeah we go to bed like way
early yeah I think I have to be in bed
by 9:00 there's 3 a.m. calls no you
gotta get to bed
yeah Disney we have notes okay we're
gonna make it better but being serious I
think a lot of people who are watching
this interview who don't really
understand the actual moviemaking
process like everyone thinks it must be
some glamorous thing you going on set
you're acting but it's like sometimes
18-hour days and it's really intense
could and this is my last thing but
could you sort of talk about that like
pull the curtain up for what it's really
like when you're making a movie always
weighing myself when it comes to like
the labor and all the hardships that
come into being you know confined to
having rubber hands on the table and
feed and teeth and eye contact and blue
makeup I drink a little bit of like blue
dye so yeah I mean a lot comes with it
that I think about but at the same time
you can level it out with all the
positives that just basically keeps me
going yeah and I mean it was up to me to
sign that contract and push the
boundaries of what I can express as an
actor going beyond just a human being
which is something I've always wanted to
do and be an optional on top of that I
mean we're really killing it yeah yeah
we were able to mimic zero-g in my
opinion quite efficiently yeah I felt
good it didn't I don't excited to see it
and Evan are usually like in in wigs and
and though we aren't necessarily blue
the same color they said yeah we're
mine's a little different roots now I
got mad roots which yeah and you're like
in and he's in rubber and I'm in rubber
and then urine rubber and everyone's
sweating you know the boots are cool
though the boots are bad they're these
really lightweight Nike shoe boots
they're amazing
the camel toes oh yeah no she's got her
God yeah yeah man that really does suck
don't it yeah you had no idea going into
it how much because but also would you
have preferred for it to be like CGI I
saw the Nike boost and I was like listen
I've seen cartoon I'm just gonna say I
really appreciated that answer
it was great and honest and I really
anyway listen I thank you so much for
coming in and I cannot wait to see the
finished film thank you thank you
you